Eight identical copies of the King James Bible
were selected for experimentation.
The first copy was placed in the machine on
the setting “Coarse.”
The output produced was one sheet of leather,
a small block of wood, a stack of rags stained
with ink, and a reel of thread.
“1:1” produced one copy of the Qur’an.
On “Fine” the output was a book with lead
pages and a golden cover, written in an unidentified
language.
On “1:1” it produced a copy of “The
Satanic Bible.”
On “Very Fine” the output was a book with
seemingly infinite pages, currently at a page
count of two million, encompassing religious
texts from all known faiths in all known languages,
as well as some religions that have previously
never been seen before.